hey guys we're about to head on a boat I
wish that I could tell you where we are
but I absolutely have no ideas so I'm
gonna try to find a sign so I can show
you where we are here's a sign is this
we are
waiting that you get on the boat or your
mixer but we gotta get time-lapse
we're now in the boat we just made a
nice little order I got a coffee and
apple strudel and I'm so excited because
I wanted it yesterday and today is the
day yeah I'm ready for the strudel I got
something else do you know where we are
okay
I don't humor I know we're in German
it's 3:00 a.m. in California right now
and I'm eating ice cream worth it so
this is apparently about a four hour
Bell ride and I've already eaten once
I've had one coffee so what we're
speaking is each hour we have a new
snack maybe it's like one of them is
like a meal
let's go take a tour of the boat shall
we let's hope we don't
we're getting off with some unknown
destination this course is unknown to me
I haven't known where we are this entire
time I keep looking on Google Maps
that's not loading so we're getting off
here for about 40 minutes we can see
them you know you have an eye on the
people clearly not because I'm walking
no I won roles we could not lose our
group I have to keep taking pictures and
video of signs so I know where we are
an ice cream cone the ice-cream cone
breaks all language barriers
fit it quick let's stop here
super cute little town now we're getting
back on the ship to head back to
wherever we came from I really do wish I
had more information for you guys but
anytime anyone tells me where I am they
don't actually know what they're saying
to me so I'm sorry I feel like you guys
in the comments will be able to tell me
where I'm at better than anybody else
will in actual real life
Jenna this boat takes off who we're not
on this boat then we go get ice cream
I had to go back for it so she might
meet the boat is starting to move oh my
god we can't leave Oh
we can't leave them here
what do we do searched this whole like
to shoot everyone
she is are gone
that's it
I was extremely nervous
we made it everything is going great
we're all here now the real dilemma is
what are we gonna eat now get the menu
Cheers teachers and German again no
that's a patient
thank you it's really good on a boat in
Israel it's always a really fine dining
establishment
may I recommend any of you come to
Germany or wherever we happen to be and
you come on this boat Caesar salad with
chicken quite delicious
you're so far away look how far away I
am you know where we are
exactly started here no here no here not
ready
all right we're back in wherever we came
from
that's where we're lighting part now
we're back in Dresden
so I guess are kind of more in the city
right now I'm really enjoying not
knowing where I am but thankfully we're
with people who live here and are from
here they can take us around and help us
us tourists folk
can somebody tell me what this says
because I would love to know what this
big rocket
I'm asking them what the sets
this is wild we're in Dresden I'm only
saying that repeatedly because I
actually know where we are that's been
the first time since for today
guys thank you so much for watching hope
you guys enjoyed this video we had so
much fun in all of these places that we
didn't know where we were so if you guys
know buddy the places that we just were
feel free to leave comments below and
let us know anywhere in Europe you think
that we should visit what should we do
and I'll see you in the next video hi